Russian President
Vladimir Putin
made a rare
in-person appearance
at a meeting of his Security Council
for the first time
since he invaded Ukraine in February.
Well, aside,
from a brief clip of the meeting
that aired on state television
showing Mr.
Putin with key members of his inner
circle,
the rest of the discussion
took place behind closed doors
Well, this comes as Ukraine has
seen has been rather
under a barrage of missile
strikes, many of them
targeting its energy infrastructure
CNN contributor and former
CNN Moscow bureau
chief Jill Dougherty
joins me now from Washington, D.C.
She's also an adjunct professor
at Georgetown University.
So good to see you, Jill.
A number of Ukrainian cities,
including the capital Kiev,
have come under attack from Russian
missiles, again,
hitting critical energy infrastructure.
Ukrainian President
Zelensky is now warning
that up to 10 million
people are in the dark with no power.
Now, the prime minister is warning
that the capital could face
a complete shutdown of its power grid,
just as temperatures
are expected to drop
to -10 degrees Celsius.
What's your read on Mr.
Putin's plan
hitting now
critical civilian infrastructure
in this phase of the war?
You know,
this is obviously part of his plan.
Both to decimate the possibility
that Ukraine Ukraine can really respond
very strongly.
After all,
this is affecting any type of power
and that affects civilians
as well as the military,
but especially civilians.
And then I think also
what he's doing
is sending a message to the West
that the price that you're going to pay
for supporting
Ukraine is going to be very, very high.
So it's really a dastardly
approach to, you know,
attacking civilians.
But that is the war
that he is waging right now.
So is very difficult
because even though they try
and I saw some reports
that they have been very quickly
trying to restore power in many cases
is going to be a very brutal
and difficult winter for Ukrainians
in a striking development.
Russian state
television aired images of Russian
President Vladimir Putin
at a meeting of his Security Council,
the first
since a long time
since February when this all began,
especially coming
after the setback in Harrison.
What message
do you think this is meant to send?
Well, you know, when he was
when he was last week
personally at a meeting
with the Security Council,
it was precisely, as you said,
at the beginning of the war.
And then after that,
he would participate.
They did participate virtually.
And, of course,
there was a lot of concern
and a lot of protection
for President Putin in terms of cold.
They've been very, very worried
about exposing him to anything.
Remember those pictures of him
at the very long table?
Well, I think physically being there
is probably a sign
to show that he's on the case.
He is, you know, talking with the
with his Security Council
that he has controlling things.
I think it's a symbol of what
they're trying to get across
is some type of stability
and strength on
the part of the president.
I know it's very difficult to gauge,
but do
we have any way of knowing
whether there is dissent
within his inner circle,
especially seeing what has happened
in this past week?
Yeah, that is always hard to gauge.
I mean, we do know that there
there is some second thought.
There are some second thoughts
about this
among some members of the elite.
But when you get into Putin's
inner circle,
it's very hard to say precisely
what is going on.
And that that is one of the problems is
his inner
circle is very small, or at least
we are led to believe that
that the people really
he is surrounded
by are people
from security forces, from the military.
And, you know, police police, FSB, etc..
So to a lot of those people, obviously,
you know,
are many times on the side of Putin
in terms
of really
taking the war to the Ukrainians
and sometimes even harsher than Mr.
Putin himself.
But it's very hard to gauge that.
We do know, however,
that we have some people
in the business community
who have spoken out.
And certainly
there is some
protest diminishing in protest
among the people themselves.
And in conclusion, Jill,
what does
the state of play on the battlefield
do for the influence of oligarchs
like Yevgeny
Ghosn, whose Wagner group
mercenary is now
literally on the front lines?
Well, I
mean, with Prigozhin
and the Wagner group,
I think it gives him, you know, business.
His people are being hired to fight.
But also,
it gives him some political clout.
He already had it.
But now in the war, he's
very important
element of the way that the Russians are
are fighting this war.
So I think his influence
certainly has increased.
That would be one thing.
And but, you know, whether or not
that really is
what's driving things, perhaps it is.
But I think
a lot of this is simply driven
by Putin himself,
who shows no sign of going back.
You know,
there's a debate in the United States
right now
in the Biden administration
as to whether or not,
you know,
they would urge Ukraine
to come to the negotiating table.
And I think, you know, the division
there is that some people feel
the Ukrainians actually
have been doing very well.
And maybe now's the time to lock in
some of those gains that there are others
who look,
as we've
just been discussing at this prospect,
the very long war,
and say,
well, you know,
the Ukrainians ought to just continue.
But we cannot tell them what to do.
That's the mantra
from this administration.
And the phrase, you know, again, is
nothing about Ukraine without Ukraine.
And they continue to say
they really need it.
Jill Dougherty, thank you so much.